I try to find common ground with people
I talk to and it's very hard because
you're a rock superstar and you know you
think how can I find Common Ground uh
with this with this man without seeming
completely deranged but I do know that
we both grew up in these environments
where what we're doing for a living or
as our art whatever we want to call it
seemed unimaginable when we were kids I
have read that about you that when you
were a young kid growing up in southwest
of England Southwest of England quiet
very yeah very quiet and you weren't a
young boy that was thinking oh I yeah I
I have my plan I'm going to be a music
Superstar well it's funny I was speaking
to this 15 year old um yesterday about
songwriting he was asking how do you
know when something's good how do you
and I was trying to explain the Duality
between absolute self-belief and
complete wonder and humility and I think
you have to keep that forever yeah but I
do think that when I was 12 or 13 and
song Started arriving
there was something in me that felt like
oh these are these are really special
but then on the other hand there was no
nothing nearby to measure it against or
no one in our even in the region had
ever gone out and done that so it did
seem impossible but I still headed
towards it if that makes sense yeah it
makes total sense to me because I was
fascinated by comedy as a as a kid I
loved doing it but I never connected the
idea that this could be something I
could do I feel that no matter where you
grow up or in what social strata if you
just have a couple of people say a
couple of the right things to you yes it
boosts you enough to get to the next
Island yes so who did you have
saying you're pretty good you could do
this you know it's funny it's so it's
like uh it's like a long slow Arc I
think and it's true for a lot of people
but there's this long slow Arc where
there are many little points along the
way where I made my friends laugh and
then I went my parents sent me to a
summer camp that I hated away in the
woods in Maine and I didn't the kids
didn't like me and I didn't like them
and then there was one counselor
that I just he thought I was the
funniest thing and he kept laughing
really hard and he kept saying are you
guys listening to this kid what's his
name I can't remember now
um I I can't remember his name but he
single-handedly got me through that
summer camp experience it was all
because he thought this kid's really
funny and then that just kept happening
and I know for you yeah you had I saw
Common Ground there you had a you had a
music teacher a couple of people that I
had
you just reminded me that in the same
year two things happened which was like
a a total microcosm of how my whole life
has turned out I played an original song
in a school concert and got booed off by
a drunk boy in the year above and at the
same time this Dad of a friend who had
been in a pretty successful band in
England he came to see a concert and I
played another song and he said you're
going to be massive this happened in
almost in the same month you know but
then the drunk kid came back
but funnily enough kind of the drunk guy
showed up backstage in Australia in 2009
and now comes to all of our shows like
the kid that booed you off stage he
might still be booing but there's more
people around him
I don't know why he's there but he's
there he's the one guy booing at a
Coldplay show I love I love that either
that or he's saying Bruce
[Laughter]
Springsteen I've seen him often after
show tears coming down because he
thought he was booed you're like no no
no I know that you took to the piano at
around 10 11. yeah
but the guitar was first I know yeah
yeah both I wouldn't say I'm very good
either but I'm I do do what you do which
is explore all the time and this is
another thing I was saying to this young
guy yesterday so many of our songs the
portal through which they arrive is some
failure that I've done on the guitar or
I'm playing the wrong thing but it
sounds good right or I'll often tune to
a different tuning so I don't know what
I'm doing yeah or play without looking
on the piano so I'm just hearing it so I
don't know if it's correct if you see
what I mean yes and often if you analyze
our songs after the fact
they're so simple that we would never
have allowed ourselves to do that have
we known or it's just e to A to B to e
but it's not because I know I mentioned
this to you once I've tried when I first
approach a Coldplay song that I love to
play there's always something like well
yellow is a really good example of that
high E string
to play it right and have it sound kind
of like I'm going to say the record just
to date myself but the recording that
that that high E string has to be tuned
slightly differently and you and there's
something about it that's there's always
something in your songs and it's a
compliment that is somewhat different do
you know what I mean even if you think
well this is just a straight B no it's
not no it's really not this goes across
my life too though uh your limitations
are become strength so oh yeah really
early on I realized I'm not going to be
the best singer of all time and I'm
definitely not as fast on guitar as my
friend Simon you know or as Wilson
Pickett I'm not going to be as good a
singer as that or t I'm never going to
dance like Tina Turner but maybe I can
make things weirdly me yes that's what I
feel so encouraged about a whole around
the whole world right now is seeing
people become themselves even if it's a
bit different yes because that's how I
feel about our music and I don't claim
it's the best but it's definitely the
most us